Now we're going to do a full 1 sample t test from start to finish. And that
includes the t test, the confidence interval, Cohen's d and r squared. We're
going to do the whole thing, just like we would in a real research study.
Before we do, it's important for you to gather some important information and
some important tools. I'm going to list these tools and the information right
here, be sure you get them. You'll need some paper and some pencils. You'll
also need a calculator that has a square root and an exponent button. You're
going to need the following formulas, so right them down on a separate sheet of
paper and keep them handy throughout this example. You're going to need to do
degrees of freedom, n minus 1. You'll also need the standard error of the mean,
which is a sample standard deviation divided by the square root of the sample
size. You're going to need the formula for the one sample t test and recall
that is the sample mean minus the population mean divided by the standard error
of the mean. The formula for the confidence interval is X bar plus or minus the
margin of error. Remember the formula for the margin of error is t critical
times the standard error of the mean. You will also need Cohen's d, which is
the mean difference divided by the standard deviation for the sample. And
finally, r squared, which is t squared over t squared plus degrees of freedom.
Again this is not t critical, this is the t that comes from the t test.